like when I have a kid like I'm so
[ __ ] up with my Inge with my anxiety
or whatever my OCD if I have a kid like
I'm so specific dude you know me you
listen to my [ __ ] you know how I am you
know I don't [ __ ] these rules and
[ __ ] that I'm joking about and all that
I'm kind of also serious a little bit
newsflash I'm serious you know but like
to have a kid and have him be like to
having a little kid for me to have a
look at it's like no I don't like to eat
pasta with sauce on it because that's
something else I'll put the sauce on the
side I will have the pasta and I will
dip as much sauce as I want on each bite
if I had like a three-year-old that was
saying that [ __ ] I'd be like Oh for
[ __ ] sake dude well maybe yell at him
that's what I do in a way not that but
you know when I go I get a brownie
sundae
I tell him to split all the [ __ ] up man
I don't want you to do it you give me
the [ __ ] things I how much percentage
of what goes in my mouth
you think I'm [ __ ] joking about that
dude so I have a kid that's like no I
don't want to wear shorts and slow
sleeve shirts because that doesn't make
sense and I'm like but this is what you
have the other shit's dirty it doesn't
matter I don't wear that I wear shorts
and short sleeves or a long pants and
long sleeves I'm gonna be like no I'm
gonna get it oh my god for [ __ ] sake
so that is two of us that have to go by
[ __ ] rules because I go by my rules
and then I see my kid and I'm like well
I gotta go by his rules too cuz I
respect that [ __ ] OCD lifestyle and
then I have two or three kids we all got
rules literally I just got to be that
[ __ ] guy with the leg brace in bed
not hey kids let's just not move all day
get post mates and we won't have to obey
any rules okay dad
for
in one room me [ __ ] no wife because
she left way before way after the
[ __ ] each kid with a different girl
because they got so fed up with all of
us after after the kid came out and
started talking she's like well I can't
deal with both of you [ __ ] and
then I got a new chick [ __ ] inside of
her and then got a new chick inside of
her three kids four beds one big studio
one big studio apartment just like kids
to wake up good morning gentlemen
remember let's not move at all
if anyone needs anything I will do it
I've been dealing with this anxiety as
long as longer than all of you put
together okay dad we'll just stay here
remember stay here till 10:00 p.m. and
then we'll go back to sleep all we do is
eat and [ __ ] out of the hole in the bed
okay how do we pee you take your PAP
[ __ ] and you just point it since we all
have big [ __ ] cuz I've got a big [ __ ]
and I've passed that down to everybody
except Craig over on the left dad how
come my character is so small I don't
know maybe your mom's dad's [ __ ] was
small we were hoping it would skip a
generation whatever I'll just piss up
into the air your penis is Craig your
penis is not big enough and it sticks
straight up because of it I'll just pee
in the air dad okay put on Netflix Tommy
okay